قام صندوق الهواء النظيف بإحضار
وحدات التلوث إلى 28 شرطي وهي عبارة عن
ثلاث قباب جيوديسية مترابطة
تحاكي تلوث الهواء من ثلاث
مدن عالمية، لذلك لدينا لندن
ونيودلهي وبكين والهدف من
جلب هذه القباب إلى الشرطة هو
عرض التأثيرات  تلوث الهواء
وكيف أن العمل على تلوث الهواء هو عمل
مناخي عمل صحي ويمكن أن
يمنع وفاة عدة ملايين
من الأشخاص، لذلك إذا أتيت معي أولاً سنمر
عبر لندن وعندما تدخل
لندن، ستشم هذه الرائحة غير اللطيفة حقًا
و  من المفترض أن يكون ثاني أكسيد النيتروجين
وهو أكاسيد النيتروجين والكثير من الانبعاثات في
لندن بسبب
المركبات في المرحلة SP التالية، سنأخذك إلى
نيودلهي وفي نيودلهي هناك أيضًا
مستويات خطيرة من تلوث الهواء
على مدار العام،
وهذا شهر حار بشكل خاص  مع
الفنان مايكل بينسكي قام بالمحاكاة
ويمكنك معرفة أن الرائحة ليست
جميلة جدًا، فهي تشعر بعدم الارتياح للغاية وذلك
لأن دلهي لديها
مستويات عالية بشكل خطير من تلوث الهواء بسبب
انبعاثات المركبات والنقل مرة أخرى
بالإضافة إلى
الانبعاثات الصناعية من جميع أنحاء المدينة.
وهناك مصادر عابرة للحدود
لتلوث الهواء تأتي من حرق الكتلة الحيوية
وإذا أتيت إلى الكبسولة التالية سنذهب
إلى بكين والمقصود من ذلك
محاكاة بكين خلال
أشهر الشتاء حيث تميل مستويات تلوث الهواء
إلى الارتفاع ومرة ​​أخرى
تتمتع بكين بمستويات غير صحية  ومستويات الهواء شديدة الخطورة
بسبب
الصناعات التي تحيط بالمدينة،
لدينا أيضًا حرق للفحم ولدينا أيضًا
انبعاثات من المركبات مرة أخرى في المرحلة النهائية
والرابعة، أردنا عرض
الحلول العالمية للعمل على الهواء النظيف
رقم واحد الذي أطلقناه للتو
مبادرة مدن التكاثر لدينا 11 مدينة
حول العالم حيث
أطلقنا للتو هذا البرنامج حيث
سندعمهم بالبيانات مع الدافع
والمطالبة والهدف هو خفض انبعاثات تلوث الهواء
بنسبة 30٪ بحلول عام 2030 وأخيرًا
لدينا  شريحة تفاعلية حيث
يمكنك بالفعل إدخال المدينة التي
تعيش فيها ويمكنك رؤية مستويات
تلوث الهواء وعدد الوفيات التي
يسببها كل
نهاية عام، يا إلهي، هذا سيء للغاية،
هذا مثل دلهي والتقاليد نفسها